the world presented in Greta gerwig's
Barbie is a cotton candy Utopia where
your house comes up with your outfits
each day the sun is always shining and
everyone lives in beautiful Harmony sure
things eventually go awry when Margot
Robbie's Barbie finds herself grappling
with flat feet and cellulite and has to
re-examine her entire existence but
Barbie land still seems pretty great you
can go back to your regular life or you
can know the truth about the universe
a choice is
the first one the high heel fans agree
in their loving gerwig's movie if
Twitter is any indication as one user
wrote genuinely surprised at how well
Barbie movie walks the line between
corporate product placement and genuine
artistic statement gerwig's smart funny
script gives the humans short shrift but
gives us two all-timer comic Creations
in margot's Barbie and Gosling's
oscar-worthy Ken another user agreed
with the sentiment completely tweeting
Barbie movie dazzles with big laughs and
plenty of pink it's one of the funniest
films of the year but also unwraps a
fresh perspective on identity the
patriarchy and being human sure there's
lots that's on the nose but it's
hilarious and Charming through and
through another user was pretty
grandiose in their assessment after
seeing the movie writing no film is
served by hyperbole but there was a
point when I was watching Barbie movie
when I thought this is the culmination
of all cinematic history another user
joined in praising Barbie tweeting
Barbie might be my favorite film of the
year so far Ryan Gosling deserves the
Oscar for an Alzheimer of a comedic
supporting turn while Margot Robbie
brings out the humanity in the doll
Greta gerwick imbues this with
impeccable social commentary meanwhile
another fan invoked Classic Hollywood in
their tweet Hollywood was built on big
bombastic flamboyant explosive movies
with stunning visuals hammy performances
Pastiche punch Pizzazz Barbie movie
throws back to the MGM musical Busby
Berkeley Technicolor epics it epitomizes
the movie going experience its literal
Cinema similarly yet another fan
compared Barbie to two radically
different concepts saying the Barbie
movie is everything the other movies are
just Ken Barbie is the Absurd love child
of Judith Butler in a muppet film it's a
blast go watch it one Twitter user kept
it simple and heartfelt writing equal
parts hilarious introspective meta and
tender Barbie is a genuine success from
every angle the most I've laughed in a
theater in years maybe ever but the
heart and soul of the movie will linger
longer than any one joke Gerwig is 3 out
of of three one user in particular
however knows this movie will be
divisive and isn't upset about it at all
to confirm having seen the movie I very
much remain a Barbie girl it is so
clever and detailed and pointed and it's
thought of all the jokes and criticisms
you could possibly make already some
people are going to hate it and I can't
wait gerwig's script in the film's
overall look are one thing but fans also
rush to Twitter to praise her wildly
talented cast with Ryan Gosling as a
standout his Ken paired with Margot
Robbie's Barbie is at once vapid and
full of emotions and fans definitely
noticed one Ken fan wrote Barbie is bold
and ambitious a film that feels Larger
than Life at times yet very Indie in
others it is quite the impressive feat
for Greta Gerwig as it truly showcases
just how impressive of a filmmaker she
is Ryan Gosling's performance is
hilarious and award-worthy yet another
Ken fan recognized that Gosling took his
chance to finally be funny and ran with
it loved Barbie the movie which is a
delightfully weird slice of meta
existentialism it's odd hilarious and
deeply moving as any good Gerwig film is
Robbie is excellent Gosling once again
proving why he's the perfect comedic
actor it's possible to acknowledge that
Robbie is incredible while also noting
that Gosling is a standout like one
Twitter user does Barbie is bursting at
the seams with extravagant creativity
Greta Gerwig made a summer bash soaked
in fun and empathy Margot Robbie is
Stellar but Ryan Gosling steals the show
magnificent production Design One user
spotlighted a different actor saying
Barbie the movie was everything I've
been dreaming of and so much more
hilarious and deeply incisive it
delivers the big feels Greta Gerwig
gives it the extra magical touch needed
to soar Margot Robbie and Ryan Gosling
are Divine but Issa Ray is my president
Barbie
one fan gave a shout out to Michael
Sarah Kate McKinnon and Will Ferrell's
character's writing the power of Greta
gerwick for being able to pull out
refreshing performances and New
Dimensions from classic comedy actors in
Barbie the movie
[Music]